die fed definierung auf sf mit di so
swiss re rb
[Musik]
die welt wandelt sich auch jene der
winzer für manche schweizer weinbauern
steht die zukunft auf dem spiel
in genf wo da mir mehr nur gegen den rat
seines vaters ins geschäft einsteigen
will
er sagte mir ganz klar mach was anderes
wer das mit leidenschaft macht opfer
gleich sein ganzes leben dafür
[Musik]
im loro piana schon dem betrieb seinen
sohn brasil übergeben hat es ist genauso
haltung mit seinen kindern zu arbeiten
die mit seinen vater jetzt habe ich das
sagen aber sicher müssen wir wachsen
[Musik]
im tessin oder das riesige weingut
tamburini nach generationen der
männerherrschaft nun von dieser jungen
frau valentina geleitet wird
als frau hat man es in diesem metier
nicht leicht es ist nach wie vor eine
männerdomäne
[Musik]
in graubünden wo ihren grünen felder
gegen den willen ihrer kinder das bio
zertifikat anstrengt
schwachsinn
auf dem weg hoch zum weingut denke ich
mir immer wunderschön da war stark
gefährdet
und im wallis wo marion brasch mit aller
kraft eines der vorzeige güte führt
sie ist die seele des weinguts begonnen
[Musik]
die winzerinnen der berggipfel die einen
nachfolger sucht
für diese fünf winzerinnen und winzer
ist der jahresverlauf voller
ungewissheit vier jahreszeiten
[Musik]
ende juni
der sommer hat gerade erst begonnen gibt
es erste anzeichen einer bevorstehenden
dürre
in beton fließt kein wasser mehr diese
leitungen versorgen das ganze weingut
direkt ab quelle
hier in beton hat es immer wasser
gegeben sonst wäre hier keine siedlung
entstanden
der zufluss des lebensnotwendigen
wassers wurde irgendwo unterbrochen
wahrscheinlich durch geröll mario muss
zum wasserfall aufsteigen
ihre beiden mitarbeiter begleiten sie
zum glück kann sie sich auf christian
verlassen
ein bauer der sich mit diesem thema
auskennt und gerade erst aus den berner
alpen hergekommen ist
ich wollte nur kurz schauen wie es da
aussieht
ja das muss alles weg das ist das
problem
das ist viel arbeit das hat ihr eine
weile dran bis das alles weggeräumt ist
wir müssen alle steinbrocken aus diesem
becken hier holen
diese steine müssen alle weg das muss
geklärt werden
ok also dahin ja wir werfen die steine
dahin nicht auf die seite sondern auf
diese seite hier
was ist so ließ die galena ziehen
wenn das jetzt austrocknet wenn die
reben die retter verlieren dann gibt es
keine ernte ganz einfach dann sterben
sie ab
im september gibt es dann vielleicht
regen dann kommen sie wieder aber die
trauben entwickeln sich so nicht mehr
richtig und das ist nicht gut
daraus doch der eine oder andere
steinberg
die steine im alter fällt
[Musik]
in bildung fließt das wasser wieder am
anderen ende des landes ganz im osten
der schweizer rehberge kämpfen auch er
in und der sohn johannes mit den folgen
der dürre
müssen egal ist hatte praktischen
ereignete aber das hatte vor allem der
die junge rebecca der verein ist so
langsam mal wieder dass man den halt ein
bisschen wasser geht also nur der
dreijährigen vierjährige wurde hat
nämlich selber kalzium geben
johannes holt nachschub
in - wurde das wasser mit dem tankwagen
angeliefert 2018 erinnert langsamen 2003
dem bisher heißesten jahr seit der
jahrtausendwende heißt also sich wehren
03.03 ist völlig falschen spiel brachte
aber als konzern hoffe dass mir nicht zu
üppige weg legen
herbstein verglichen und gemüse frische
toni das ip oder zu dichter wie gelegt
um die reben anlage gegen die dürre zu
wappnen hat er in eine eigene strategie
entwickelt das gut weil sie gern sehr
tiefe wurzeln und männer zum leben halte
gebäude also was relativ gut zu kalt ich
selber finde aber die muss lernen to
figure weil man immer und immer dreister
geht in den ländlich und der nächste
mehr funktioniert braucht erhalte
gestorben
bei grünen fee das trägt man den böden
besonders sorge denn dieses jahr möchte
ihren sich für das bio siegel
zertifizieren lassen
jedes detail zählt
[Musik]
aber jetzt hoffen wir dass nirgends in
malawi träger kommen
sanfte regen und hagel
[Musik]
im lavo herrscht ebenfalls wassermangel
auch wenn das auf den ersten blick nicht
so scheint an den hängen in riva macht
brasil einen rundgang durch parzellen
und trifft dabei auf seine nachbarn
[Musik]
na wie geht's gut und dir ziemlich
trocken
hast du gesehen fast alle geist triebe
sind verdacht hier ist noch einer der es
noch gut aber auch schon etwas gelb hier
erkennt man sehr gut dass er war dort
ist gut dass sie bewässert aber das ist
auch eine trockene ecke hier oder ja
dass hier sind böden die stark filtern
und entwässern
daher ist es trocken bewässert die hier
zum ersten mal ja das erste mal
ich habe den betrieb 2015 übernommen
wir haben einen trockenen frühling und
einen trockenen sommer anfang der regen
kommt einfach nicht und ich weiß nicht
genau wie ich damit umgehen soll
das wachstum ist gehemmt die reben
entwickeln sich nicht so wie das
normalerweise der fall ist da fehlt
einfach die erfahrung
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit etwas weiter weg
macht sich basels vater pierre monahan
vizepräsident der winzer bruderschaft
auf dem weg um die fed definierung
anzupreisen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren hier blicken wir
auf etwa 400.000 rebstöcke und zu ehren
all dieser rebstöcke unter winzer die
sie bewirtschaften eröffnen wir in
wenigen augenblicken denn wir verkaufen
für die fette senioren 2009 10
vielen dank der verkaufsstart der bse
ist ein bedeutender moment für die
organisatoren die hoffen dadurch die
finanzierung der nächsten fed sichern zu
können
trotz dieser herausforderung kommt er
nicht umhin auch an andere probleme zu
denken jene die den betrieb betreffen
mein sohn möchte er in richtung bioanbau
gehen
das hat dazu geführt dass er dieses jahr
im frühling dann zu viel unkraut hatte
was die reben eingeengt hat die pflanzen
die blüten leiden darunter tragen
leichte trauben die sind schon gut aber
dieses jahr ist es wirklich sehr trocken
na ja er wird sich an diesem moment
zurück
er musste diese erfahrung machen jetzt
weiß er es besser
in einer vater-sohn-beziehung kommt
immer irgendwann der moment
ich habe vermutlich mit meinem vater das
gleiche gemacht als sohn sagt man sich
dann der alte mann geht mir auf die
nerven mit seinen ratschlägen
ich will es auf meine art machen also
macht er so wie er will
aber da steckt auch viel erfahrung
dahinter ja schon aber das muss ja
nichts heißen
das ist jetzt ein problem wir hatten
anfangs den ehrgeiz einen möglichst
biologischen weinbau zu betreiben unter
geringem einsatz von unkrautvernichtern
aber angesichts der umstände musste ich
die ansprüche etwas herunterstufen
es kam der punkt an dem wir gezwungen
waren herbizide einzusetzen um den reben
etwas luft zu verschaffen
das ist verrückt denn anfangs sah es gut
aus die dicke der triebe war eigentlich
gut und dann verlangsamte sich das
wachstum plötzlich sich ständig anpassen
jede saison aufs neue immer im wissen
dass man als winzer nur einen einzigen
versuch pro jahr hat entscheidend ist
immer das endergebnis das heißt dass der
wein am ende hervorragend sein muss
nicht nur gut sondern hervorragend so
ist es nun mal
letztlich kann war sie da so viele dinge
ausprobieren wie er möchte
was zählt ist dass das endprodukt
hervorragend ist
für mich war immer nur das beste gut
genug und für ihn ist das auch so aber
bei manchen versuchen muss man dennoch
sehr aufpassen
nun ist er es der den wein dann
verkaufen muss
[Musik]
in genf nach den frühlings gewittern
kümmert sich dann ja um die gesundheit
seiner pflanzen den melo finde ich
besonders schön
vor allem wegen seiner blätter aber er
hat lange gebraucht um sich zu erholen
hier sieht man noch immer die spuren des
hagels vom letzten mal
die hagelkörner haben überall schaden
angerichtet vor allem an den ranken
es freut mich die pflanze jetzt so zu
sehen so grün und bald kommen die
trauben
sie ist auch frei von krankheiten daher
sind wir wirklich zufrieden
jetzt gilt es die sommer krankheiten
fernzuhalten
bei der nachbarzelle ist es anscheinend
zu einem befall durch echten und
falschen mehltau gekommen
dieses weingut gehört im kanton genf und
dessen önologe ist zufällig gerade vor
ort
hier sieht man dass ein großteil der
weinbeeren betroffen ist sie sind
bereits ausgetrocknet
zudem ist auch das blattwerk gefallen
und hier ist der schaden an trauben und
blättern sehr gut zu erkennen
beunruhigend der weiße belag hier
das sind mehltau spuren die dann vom
wind verbreitet werden und neue blätter
und bären befallen können
da steckt ein riesiges schaden potenzial
drin mehltau ist hoch ansteckend wenn
man ihn einmal hat wird man ihn nicht
mehr los
daniel kann nur hoffen dass diese sich
nicht auf seine partielle ausbreiten
solche beispiele zeigen dass es im laufe
der saison gewisse momente gibt in denen
man wirklich keinen messbaren darf
genauso ist es in solchen schwierigen
jahren merkt man was bio anbau nicht
ganz so einfach ist man muss viel
wachsamer sein
ja das ist klar manchmal ist es
notwendig in guten jahren das maximum
herauszuholen um dann die schwierigeren
jahre zu überstehen
man muss mit verlusten leben können und
lernen wie man mit krankheiten umgeht
die gesetze der natur akzeptieren oder
sich vor der natur schützen auf den
anhöhen luganos bei tamburini setzt man
nicht auf bio anbau
die arbeiter haben die reben gesprüht
und netze gegen die unwetter gespannt
[Musik]
auf diesem 70 hektaren grossen weingut
das von valentina geführt wird greift
man auf industrielle schutz methoden
zurück
[Musik]
der betrieb ist so groß geworden dass es
nicht mehr drin liegt dass ich an den
rebstöcken oder im weinkeller arbeitet
auch heute steht für valentina vida
öffentlichkeitsarbeit an
[Musik]
in einem großen restaurant in lugano an
einer sogenannten ladies night
inmitten der unternehmerinnen berichtet
valentina über ihre erfahrungen als
geschäftsführerinnen des weinguts
guten abend vorher will ich gar nicht
dazu gekommen sie alle zu begrüßen
herzlich willkommen
ich engagiere mich zu 200 prozent in
unserem familienbetrieb als vertreterin
der nächsten generation und auch als
frau
es ist natürlich nicht immer einfach mit
all diesen männern mit meinem vater
meinem großvater und auch mit all meinen
mitarbeitern einschließlich der
sinologen und der kellermeister alles
männer
ihre ansprache kommt gut an zumindest
bei den frauen
was die männer anbelangt so trifft
valentina auf einen der wenigen
vertreter seines geschlechts an diesem
abend
[Musik]
hallo wie geht's es ist ein wirklich
schöner abend ist alles gut gelaufen ja
sehr gut
valentina hat gelernt mit männern
umzugehen
ich bin unter männern aufgewachsen ich
komme gut damit klar fühle mich wohl
männer sind einfacher als frauen wegen
morgen
ich musste etwas umorganisieren mattia
wird kommen ich kann nicht überall sein
kein problem morgen wird mattia hier
seien wunderbar
heute abend bin ich da und kein problem
ich kann nicht alles gleichzeitig machen
ist einfach ein bisschen schade um den
anblick her auf es bringt nicht stark
genug machen wir es wie die hexen
an diesem frühen morgen im juli treffen
mario und ihre enkelin galliani gerade
vorbereitungen um das bio dynamische
weingut zu besprühen
über dem feuer wird ein präparat aus
kieselerde also quarzsand hergestellt
dass die rebstöcke kräftigt und schützt
holst du die kieselerde
[Musik]
nicht fallenlassen geld es ist kostbar
werbebriefe viel ist das etwa schon
zwölf gramm für dreieinhalb hektar 3 x 4
12 14 im sommer streuen wir kieselerde
aus sie gibt dem boden energie denn
mikroorganismen im boden mit der kraft
dieser biodynamischen präparate die
wirklich medizin für den boden sind
erzählen wir viel gesündere lebensmittel
das ziel ist es einen gesunden
fruchtbaren boden mit einer creme
struktur zu ziehen ein bisschen raus so
die hand etwas hoch damit man mehr sie
du musst gut aufpassen
ja aber du musst stopp sagen gebt den
schlauch bitte etwas an so wunderbar
wenn wir die wir das land bewirtschaften
unseren schönen krümeligen brunnen
anschauen und ihn mit konventionellem
boden vergleichen
dann müssen wir nicht lange überleben
man kann ihn anfassen ihn riechen und
wenn man sieht was da wächst die
pflanzen haben eine andere struktur
sie wachsen in die höhe und stehen
zwischen himmel und erde tragen
glänzende blätter bei den reden zeigt
sich das sehr deutlich
ganz leicht oder geht es ja
besprühen auf dieser seite den armen
apfelbaum
super hier drücken auch noch
mal wie ruhig es ist die ruhe vor dem
sturm sozusagen
[Musik]
in riva bereitet sich basel auch gerade
auf das besprühen vor
ebenfalls im morgengrauen um der hitze
auszuweichen
anderer ort andere methoden die von
generation zu generation weitergegeben
werden
nur die art und die geräte sind heute
anders sie ziehen einen schutzanzug an
da hat sich einiges getan ich habe
damals mit meinem vater angefangen er
tat das mit nacktem oberkörper eine
mütze einer zigarette im mund am abend
war er jeweils ganz blau aber die jungen
heute machen das anders
sie tragen einen overall eine
schutzmaske schutzbrille und das obwohl
die mittel heute viel weniger aggressiv
sind als früher
[Musik]
heute muss brasil die ganzen drei
hektaren des guts besprühen
an einem einzigen tag die gesamte
zukünftige ernte schützen unter dem
geringstmöglichen einsatz von chemischen
produkten
ich stehe mit einem bein im bioanbau mit
dem anderen im konventionellen anbau so
lange kräuter honig und großmutters
hausmittel funktionieren ist das für
mich in ordnung und so jongliert man
dann mit diesen beiden ansätzen
heute hat sich basel für ein mittel auf
kupfer und schwefel basis entschieden
stoffe die als natürlich gelten auch
wenn es nicht so scheint
wir schützen uns sehr gut obwohl die
mittel letztlich natürlich sind wenn man
einen spritzer ins gesicht bekommt dann
passiert nichts
das im mittel aus dem biologischen
weinbau ich weiß noch mein großvater
schützte sich natürlich nie so truger
verletzungen davon hat der scharf an den
armen und so weiter ich weiß nicht ob es
anders gewesen wäre hätte er sich
geschützt aber wir achten schon auf
solche details
[Musik]
in graubünden hat er ihn den schritt
gewagt diesen sommer erwartet sie den
besuch des inspektors der je das
biosiegel ausstehen kann
und heute ist es nun soweit je nachdem
es liegt ja und dieser antwortete martin
säckl nach heads-up trifft damit der
lose waren weg natürlich beobachte ja
das ist tatsächlich nur grundsätzlich
tun zb die bauarbeiten werden was in
greven
die handys dem hk für ganz wenig gesetz
praktisch nicht da sind bleibt es zum
teil selber wieder zu bieten
aber da die dauer ausläuft mit meter
überhaupt katharina
das war nicht der erste besuch des
inspektors er hat sich eine meinung
gebildet
[Musik]
voll im griff bis auf gutem weg und bio
prozent dass du die schon länger damit
befassen
und eigentlich schon länger biologisch
und was genau für ihre hin verlief
dieser besuch problemlos und ohne
überraschungen
[Musik]
im august in genf glück trifft sich mit
tanja vater und sohn zählen nun die tage
bis zur ernte ich denke die blütezeit
steht fest wir sind jetzt auch schon bei
100 tagen
bald werden sie reif und dann muss es
schnell gehen wir können uns schon mal
darauf einstellen dass die erntezeit
etwas kürzer sein wird als sonst ich bin
nicht sicher aber ich denke schon
daher werden wir wohl nicht den
zuckergehalt haben den man in heißen
sonnigen jahren erwartet wie gesagt ich
weiß es nicht so genau aber es ist auch
eher untypisch wir werden sehen aber es
ist nicht wie 2003 und auch nicht wie
2015 gut wahrscheinlich fangen wir mit
den insgesamt es ist nicht schlecht aber
wir könnten uns den reifegrad ja mal
kurz anschauen brauchen auch gut zwei
wochen denke ich ja witzig die kerne
sind ja noch ziemlich grün aber sie sind
schon knackig beim drauf beißen findest
du nicht
ja also einige sind schon ganz hübsch
die entwicklung ist auf gutem weg
dann müssen wir schauen wie die werden
diese beeren sind noch etwas da sind
schon welt wieder abgestoßen wurden die
werden verdorren denke ich und die hier
sind etwas verdeckt
es ist wirklich schön was bereitet
freude die reben so zu sehen
um die erntezeit abschätzen zu können
vertraut auf die erfahrung die ihm sein
vater vermittelt hat und doch ist er es
der entscheidet an welchem tag und zu
welcher uhrzeit es soweit ist
er beobachtet und probiert die trauben
nutzt die erkenntnisse aus der langen
tradition des weinbaus seinem gut nun
beginnt für alle schweizer winzer die
lange zeit des wartens
[Musik]
gegen ende des sommers sind die trauben
zwar noch nicht ganz bereit für die
ernte aber für manche doch schon sehr
schmackhaft da wurde alles abgefressen
das waren die vögel aber wir haben auch
schon taxi und rehe gehabt und das ist
erst der anfang
danach kommen die ameisen hier sind
sicher schon 23 ameisen am werk die
reden müssen mit netzen geschützt werden
ihr landarbeiter christian ist gegangen
nun sucht mario nach einem ersatz
eigentlich sollte ich arbeiten nicht
herum spazieren
jetzt haben wir einiges zu tun netze
spannen die birnen pflücken und viele
andere dinge
es ist zwar nicht die ernte aber dennoch
arbeiten die angestellten ihrer kollegin
marie teresa sind zur verstärkung
bekommen
selbst ihr bei marie theres auch die
blauen nicht sein
ja die gleichen auf der anderen seite
fressen schon die rede die trauben ab
auf der anderen seite ja letztes jahr
hatten wir auch schon probleme ja da
waren es die vögel und dann die räder
es gab frost wenig an den pflanzen kaum
ja im flachland gab es frust der gast
ganz eingefroren unten bei der seilbahn
aber dieses jahr ist es schön es ist
trotzdem eine schöne arbeit wir haben
noch viele netze zu spannen falls ihr
noch mal wiederkommen wollte
[Musik]
kurz vor der ernte müssen die trauben
noch besonders geschützt werden
nach unwettern und krankheiten müssen
die winzer jetzt auch noch maßnahmen
gegen den andrang der tiere ergreifen
nach diesem trockenen sommer sind die
wildtiere hungrig und durstig von den
insekten ganz zu schweigen
die sind schon reif da haben sich schon
die wespen bienen und vögel dran zu
schaffen gemacht
wenn das wetter warm und wendig bleibt
sollte das aber kein problem sein aber
wenn für sonntag und montag regen
angesagt ist erscheint der leider der
fall zu sein um zwei tage vielleicht
okay wir richten uns danach
abgesehen von den westen bedroht auch
eine kleine fliege die reben
sie hat die arbeiter dazu gezwungen die
tauben mit einem eigenartigen gemisch zu
besprühen
ricoh ist das alles ja das ist der lohn
für euren die ahnung aber ihr musstet
die reden doch noch mit diesen weißen
pulver schützen
pauli oder pierre du kennst dich da
besser aus carolin das ist weiße tonerde
die federico als vorsichtsmaßnahme
angesetzt hat vorbeugend gegen die
kirche es ich fliege wann war das vor
einer woche
diese neue eindringling bereitet
valentina sorgen eine kleine asiatische
fliege die die ernte ruinieren kann
die fliege legt ihre eier im innern der
traube dadurch entsteht eine essigsäure
gärung die die weinherstellung sehr
schwierig macht
die vier betroffenen trauben müssen
zwingend entfernt werden denn mit ihnen
kann kein wein mehr hergestellt werden
der essig geruch ist wirklich sehr stark
die griechen auf jeden fall nicht nach
es nur ein paar wenige kleine trauben
sind beschädigt im moment haben wir hier
also noch keinen befall aber sie müssen
noch zwei wochen durchhalten
[Musik]
zwei wochen vor der ernte kann man die
daumen drücken oder feiern an diesem
letzten august wochenende öffnet ihren
die tore ihres weingut für die breite
öffentlichkeit
anlass ist eine kleine feier die sie
gemeinsam mit tochter europa und sohn
johannes auf die beine gestellt hat wir
treffen johanna sonderbar an wo er
gerade zwei stars des deutschen
fernsehens versichert die fernsehköche
scheinen schweizer beine zu schätzen
100 und ein teil kalkulation gemacht
damit er bis farbe kriegt und teil
ganz abgepresst das mit der die frische
kombinieren zum essen das situation
stünde fett gemacht
der heute internationale ruf der bündner
weine schafft eine große nachfrage für
dieses kleine gebiet so kurz vor der
ernte erhöht sich dadurch der druck auf
die qualität der lese konstante bleibt
weil nicht wie immer wenn es nicht
richtig sehen die zu hoch ist haben auch
einfluss von alkohol aber das ist ja
logisch sind können müssen august gehen
aber die lage ist dass neuer für spiele
oder da ist vogelfraß
er hat viel dahinter der panik sei jetzt
sehr stimmen dass sie das sehen dass man
das zum teil hin aber das ist vielleicht
genau dort rauchen stress bedingt
die meisten wünsche mir dass man kühlen
nächten und war mit 26 maximal über
sonst geraten er bei wenigen und
norweger das war eine gute frage hagen
[Musik]
bist du eine kleine traube essen trauben
mädchen willst du ja aber nur eine hier
ganz vorsichtig hier vorsichtig ja wohl
und dann kommt noch eine traube in papas
tasse damit schauen kann wie es um den
zuckergehalt steht auch noch ein
das sind stichproben jetzt rücken die
trauben damit der saft heraus fließt da
mir hat verstärkung dabei für die letzte
amtshandlung vor der ernte den zucker
grad der trauben ermitteln wir machen
sagt er ist leicht rosa siehst du mal
dass ein bisschen es kommt dann hier
drauf machst du das machst du das hier
drauf auf das glas wunderbar so jetzt
machen wir das noch mal richtig weil es
ist doch relativ wichtig so dann machen
wir dazu und dann schauen wir durch
dieses kleine chor in richtung sonne
dieses gerät misst die grad oechsle
je höher der zuckergehalt desto mehr
alkohol produziert dabei einen
basiswissen in der chemie des weinbaus
die beiden zwillinge haben das schon
ganz gut drauf
naja willst du auch mal durch gar nicht
so leicht dass durch das kleine loch
schauen
trotz wärme und zucker grad der trauben
entscheidet er sich noch etwas zu
gedulden
[Musik]
in riva hingegen zeigt sich ein
außergewöhnliches schauspiel
außergewöhnlich für den monat august
ich habe noch nie im august geerntet das
ist das erste mal dass es dazu kommt das
ist vielleicht außergewöhnlich oder
vielleicht doch nicht vielleicht wird
das in zukunft auch immer wieder mal
vorkommen grüne ernte nennt sich das
vielleicht die früheste überhaupt in der
geschichte dieses weinguts mann war es
letztes jahr hier ich weiß es nicht mehr
genau
aber so um den zwanzigster september
eine ausnahme entscheidung für eine
rebsorte die nicht warten kann
der pinot noir ist vermutlich die
empfindlichste rote rebsorte daher muss
man sie wohl oder übel am tag iks ernten
wenn man zulässt dass der zucker sich
anreichert und das dann schlecht mit der
anreicherung und entwicklung der aromen
korreliert hat man am ende einen im
alkohol unausgewogenen wein
das wollen wir auf keinen fall daher
nimmt man sie lieber etwas früher damit
der alkoholgehalt stimmt der wein
schmeckt trotzdem gut die trauben sind
ja nicht mehr grün nach der lese kommt
alles für eine woche in einer kühlkammer
damit sich die weintrauben etwas setzen
können
[Musik]
die ernte muss doch gefeiert werden
es ist das erste mal dass wir die lese
im august durchführen
aber nur ganz knapp heute ist der 31 na
dann zum wohl sowohl danke dass ihr
gekommen seid
an diesem ersten tag durften pieren
brasil auf die unterstützung von familie
und freunden zählen die erntehelfer
werden in ein paar tagen eintreffen
hast du die leute für die ernte zusammen
singen noch nicht ganz
soll ich mich darum kümmern nein das
mache ich
guten tag da mehr freue mich wir haben
früher in der woche vom 10
september anzufangen aber das genaue
datum müssen wir noch bestätigen
aber so ist es geplant wir werden in der
woche wohl drei bis vier tage arbeiten
und dann in der woche darauf
weitermachen würde das für sie passen
super da freue ich mich
vielen dank für den anruf schönen tag
noch
wir haben schöne trauben an den reben
sieht alles gut aus
das wird eine schöne ernte denke ich
wenn denn das wetter hält
[Musik]
in bildung bereitet sich mario alleine
vor es ist das zweite jahr in dem sie
sich ohne joggi um die lese kümmern muss
ich habe noch nicht alles erledigt ich
habe den kontrolleur angerufen um ihm zu
sagen dass wir mit der ernte begonnen
haben aber er hat sich nicht mehr
gemeldet und sonst noch etwas besonderes
die liefermenge oder die anzahl
kilogramm müssen berechnet werden wie
immer aber das muss nicht gleich heute
sein
nein wir haben dafür fast einen monat
zeit erster obligatorische schritt für
marion den kantonalen beauftragten
informieren
guten tag ich beginne jetzt mit der
ernte in beton
also falls es da noch etwas besonderes
zu beachten gebe könnten sie mich bitte
zurückrufen danke schönen tag noch und
auf wiederhören
wir sind gelernter landwirt er wir
wollen keine zeit mit dem ausfüllen von
formularen verlieren mit der bürokratie
die immer mehr wird so fehlt uns dann
die zeit um unseren eigentlichen beruf
auszuüben
aber so ist es nun mal da muss man sich
halt führen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in bildung sind gerade die erntehelfer
angekommen
aus aller welt und in allen rehberge
nist der startschuss für die ernte
gefallen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wunderschön
farbige kisten zieren die schweizer
hänge bereit für die früchte eines
ganzen jahres
[Musik]
wenige wochen für die ernte der arbeit
eines ganzen jahres und letztlich das
urteil
er hat sich gegen den einsatz von
herbiziden entschieden und bezahlten
preis dafür ganz klar das gleichgewicht
zwischen quantität und qualität finden
das ist eine schöne leser die ernte hier
werden die spannungen sichtbar
ich habe möglicherweise etwas gesagt
dass ihm nicht gepasst hat und nun ist
er weg wenige tage an denen alles kippen
kann
ich wollte nur was holen und schon bin
ich von der leiter gefallen von schmerz
bis leidenschaft überall in der schweiz
erleben die winzer den höhepunkt eines
ganzen jahres
[Musik]
die fed definierung auf sf mit die swiss
und leo p